the investigation into former president
Trump and the FBI seizure of records
from Mar-A-Lago has captured the
nation's attention but it's not the
first time that someone has been accused
of taking items without permission that
belonged to the National Archives
a review by CBS News finds a series of
recent criminal cases in which
historical artifacts were stolen
sometimes from inside the secured walls
of National Archives facilities as
correspondent Scott McFarland reports
some of the stolen history is obscure
eccentric
and priceless
many people keep old record collections
and even more of us keep piles of old
heirlooms in the basement here we have
Bob Hope but David golden has a basement
unlike any in history it's actually a
collection of history and that that will
record for about an hour Golden's a
retired radio engineer in a
climate-controlled chamber in his
Connecticut home golden stores his
unparalleled collection of historic
audio recordings items he's recorded off
the air or hunted down since he was a
kid you have hundreds of recordings the
last time I counted I had a hundred and
twenty thousand seven hundred one
hundred twenty thousand seven hundred
recordings yes from the radio call of
the 1948 World Series to an original
copy of Orson Welles 1938 War of the
Worlds to dispatches from the front
lines of World War II
is there room for anything more well I'm
thinking of kicking my wife out but I
haven't broken the idea to her yet
over the years he's donated thousands of
his artifacts to the National Archives
including a one-of-a-kind recording of
Babe Ruth bird hunting in 1937. so what
did you think one day when you go on
eBay and you see it for sale I said holy
expletive
um that can't be the Babe Ruth clip was
stolen an inside job lifted then put up
for sale by a then National Archives
employee named Les Waffen golden alerted
authorities who arrested Waffen who
often pleaded guilty to theft and served
about a year in prison for stealing
thousands of artifacts but Waffen isn't
the only one in 2018 a judge sentenced
historian antonine de Hayes to a year in
prison for stealing historic pieces that
included a Tuskegee airman's dog tags
from the National Archives Maryland
holding facility a CBS News Review shows
federal inspectors have launched about a
half dozen in investigations into
thousands of stolen archives records
over the past decade attorney Kell
McClanahan is an expert on government
records you have to go to Extreme
Measures to get something out of the
archive that they don't want you to get
out I mean it's not Fort Knox but
it's secure they treat it like a
high-end luxury goods store but perhaps
no theft was as ambitious as Barry
landau's I think he just thought he
could get away with it he had so long up
to then he'd gotten away with it Landau
stole historic presidential artifacts
from archives and private collections
from New York to Maryland including
dozens of artifacts from the Maryland
Center for history and culture in
Baltimore where a decade ago he tried to
distract the staff with cupcakes and
charm as he pocketed these early 20th
century papers these have extraordinary
historical value because they are the
history of the country literally
pocketed them using a specially designed
sport coat with extra pocket spaces sewn
inside until an eagle-eyed employee
spotted him in the ACT there's somebody
up there correct as a lookout yes Landau
pleaded guilty and served nearly seven
years in prison stolen records case is
often require years to solve or even
protect with millions of historic
records what's missing could long go
overlooked unless the donor himself
spots or hears it like Dave golden so
you knew it was yours oh yeah I knew it
was mine or if the archives or Library
staff realize or spot Something Fishy
the National Archives has its own
recovery team internal inspectors who
track down lost or stolen artifacts and
here at the Maryland Center for history
and culture they made some security
upgrades after those steps a few years
ago among other things they added
security cameras
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Scott
McFarlane in Baltimore
it's like NCIS Maryland history and
culture well it seems like nowadays with
a number of cameras yeah it's much
trickier to be able to figure out a way
to do it so that nobody would see it
yeah well the camera's definitely but
the guy who he gave the staff cupcakes
yeah and then put these long Pockets
inside that's a great move though yeah
no I I think it's a great move it's a
criminal movement
yes yeah yeah well we'll see how how
many years other people might possibly
receive for
things like this